les enfants de marioupol au jeu rythmée
par le bruit des bombes
et leurs parents qu'ils essaient de les
rassurer comme ils peuvent
cela ne fait que deux jours que macha 12
ans et sa petite soeur valéria huit ans
ose s'aventurer quelques heures dans
cette cour
avant j'avais peur de tout du moindre
bruit
mais petit à petit tu t'habitues tu
t'habitues et tu t'habitues
on peut se rassurer en se disant que
soit ils tirent difficile soit-elle tirs
au loin
pour mettre les enfants à l'abri le 18
mars ils ont cherché à quitter le centre
de marioupol alors en plein combat ils
ont dû reculer au bout de quelques
mètres
on était en route les grands parents et
les enfants à l'arrière mois devant
quand on a tourné devant le théâtre
quelque chose a explosé
et le pare-brise a volé en éclats
de sa machette valérien ne parle pas
depuis plusieurs semaines elles vivent
sous terre dans cette cave presque sans
lumière
avec 12 autres personnes
là c'est moi qui dois et là c'est ma
soeur elle nous raconte qu'elle se cache
sous la couverture quand les
bombardements sont trop forts
valeria elle est plus timide
elle veut nous montrer ses poupées
et leur petit chat
tu as peur n'aie pas peur
juste rentrer à la maison et aller à
l'école fermée activités jusqu'aux
collines se vivre comme avant l'école a
été endommagé par un tir ils ne savent
pas ce qui est arrivé à leur maison
des enfants qui ont aussi vécu la mort
de leur grand mère dans cette cave
et l'afad infarctus
son coeur n'a pas tenu le coup quand les
tirs ont touché le quartier
et vous
quand ils ont pu ils l'ont enterré eux
mêmes à quelques mètres de là juste en
face du théâtre de mario paul
où voulez-vous qu'on l'en terre on l'a
fait ici quand on est sorti ça tirait
très fort donc on est allé dans la cour
et on l'a enterré ici on pouvait pas
aller plus loin c'était trop dangereux
leur espoir maintenant c'est que leurs
enfants ne soient pas traumatisés qu'ils
oublient vite ce cauchemar pour pour
tourner la page ils veulent être
évacuées le plus vite possible de mario
paul